one of the best ways to learn how to
make decisions political business and
relationships or otherwise is to look at
history to see how past decisions have
played out for better or for worse
Richard had low his if anything a
first-rate historian another excellent
way to learn about making decisions is
to go to school to seek guidance of
teachers
Richard head low he's also a highly
respected teacher and his book is a
great class to sign up for observing
role models is important it is a great
strength of Giants of enterprise to
provide seven outstanding role models
for which from which to gather wisdom
individuals of extreme talent in a
country that nurtured their talents
professor Ted Lowe is an individual of
no small talent and accomplishment
himself he is the class of 1949
professor of Business Administration at
the Harvard Business School or he is a
specialist in the history of business he
came to the Harvard Business School on a
fellowship in 1978 and joined the
faculty 1979 from 79 to 82 he taught
first year marketing his involvement in
marketing has continued and he had been
a member of the Faculty of the strategic
retail management seminar the top
management seminar for retailers and
suppliers managing brand meaning and the
strategic marketing management executive
education programs from 1978 to the
present he has been involved in the
school's business history program in
1992 and 93 he taught a course entitled
business government and the
international economy he's also taught
in numerous executive programs at the
Harvard Business School as well as at
such corporations as Intel AOL Time
Warner and General Motors including
programs in marketing strategy and
general management it's a great
privilege to have him here at the
wordsworth podium please join me in
welcoming Richard hello
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed thanks for coming and thanks for
having me it's a it's a thrill frankly
to be I mean I've shopped here so often
and to you know to find myself here now
is a very nice thing for me what I try
to do in this book is right almost
conversationally I wanted to write a
book that speaks to people the way that
I'm speaking now and the way that we're
gonna have a dialogue if you have any
questions that you have about it and the
idea was to take a look at American
business and to see how it changed over
time by looking at a couple of key
figures in American business history and
these people start way back in the 1840s
and 1850s Andrew Carnegie is the first
one he's born in 1835 comes to the
United States in 1848 begins to become a
force in business in 1860 and by 1880s
is a Titan of enterprise and it's a name
that we all know following Carnegie I
moved to George Eastman who brings us to
upper New York State Eastman founded
Kodak and and like Carnegie and like the
other giants of enterprise in this book
it was a man possessed of a searing
insight and a great deal of
self-confidence in order to make that
inside come true and in his particular
case the insight was that if you make a
camera inexpensive enough photography is
going to become a mass marketed item
this was news when Eastman bought his
first camera in 1877 it cost forty nine
dollars and fifty cents if you had taken
a poll among people's and and asked them
would you like to become a photographer
would you like a picture they wouldn't
have known what you were talking about
he's been changed all that and by 1900
brought out the Kodak Brownie which cost
one dollar and and he brought it out
with one of the great advertising
slogans ever you push the button we do
the rest
the next giant of enterprise is Henry
Ford who is a disturbing character in
the book in that the first 40 years of
his life are are quite inspirational
Henry Ford's the the individual who put
America on wheels
it was he who
after this extremely supple period of
experimentation with the model a the B
the C the F the K the end the or the s
finally comes out with a Model T in 1908
it's a low-priced model which is
inexpensive and not cheap a very
important distinction and he he takes
this automobile and with it brings
America into the auto industrial age
before any other country in the world
the problem with Henry Ford was that a
he believed his own press notices and B
he lived alone if he had died in 1914
he'd be remembered as a true Paragon
instead he lives on into the 20s into
the 30s and the dark side of a
personality that was Manichaean in
nature had both a dark and a bright side
became more assertive until finally
frankly we were well rid of him
the next character in the book is Thomas
J Watson senior who is not literally but
virtually the founder of IBM and Watson
also was possessed of a searing insight
and his searing insight was that
business is about information when he
first took that company over in 1914 it
was called computing tabulating and
recording computing was not the
forerunner of computers computing had to
do with with scales think you know it
butcher shops recording was time clocks
it was tabulating that T that that was
the true forerunner of computers and
what what what Watson understood and
what we taught when I taught first year
marketing was was mentioned what Watson
understood was that business is about
information and so he decided that that
he was going to concentrate CTR which is
what IBM used to be called computing
tabulating and recording it was called
that from 1911 when it was founded until
1926 when Watson changed its name he was
going to focus on the tabulating part of
it the most important decision any
business ever makes is what products
it's going to sell into what markets
what markets do we like to serve with
what products he chose to serve the
market for information
and he chose to serve with tabulating
machines and if you make that decision
right you can make a lot of wrong
decisions and life will still work out
ok the next character in the book is
Charles Revson and a name not as well
known to most people but in the 1950s
and 60s and 70s it was an extremely
well-known name Charles Jefferson was
the founder of Revlon he founded it in
on March 1st 1932 as a nail polish
company this is in the midst of the
depression does this sound like a good
idea you know answer no why does it work
because Revson also had this insight and
the insight was that for a relatively
small amount of money if you could make
someone feel a little touch of glamour
in a time when things weren't so good in
this country that there was a market
there something else that's very
interesting about Charles Revson is that
his firm Revlon sponsors the $64,000
question in 1955 which is this fixed
rigged quiz show and in 1955 Revlon also
goes public and he becomes one of the
wealthiest men in the country the last
two people about whom I speak in the
book are Sam Walton and Robert Noyce Sam
Walton brings us below the mason-dixon
line
Walmart is located in Bentonville
Arkansas Walton also had a Siri in sight
just like the others in the book his
searing insight was small towns could
support big stores and they could
support big stores if the bargains in
those stores were such as to greatly
increase the trading area so as people
would drive from miles around to go to a
Walmart and he built out from that
insight delivered more than he promised
and his ambition in 1945 when he started
in the retail trade was to become the
best five-and-ten-cent operator
five-and-ten-cent stores don't exist
anymore but they used to his ambition
was to become the best five-and-ten-cent
store operator in all of Arkansas and he
overshot the mark and became the best
retailer in the history of the world and
the last character in the book takes us
finally to the West we start off in
Scotland with Carnegie me wind hop wind
up in silicon
and that character is Bob Noyce noise
once again is a name that's not as
well-known as it ought to be Robert
Noyce was the co-inventor of the
integrated circuit along with a man
named Jack Kilby who in the year 2000
won the Nobel Prize for inventing the
integrated circuit noise would all if he
had lived that long he died in 1990 if
he had lived to be 72 he would have won
a nobel prize - because he Co invented
the integrated circuit his integrated
circuit had a silicon substrate Kilby's
at Texas Instruments his integrated
circuit had a germanium substrate it
turns out that silicon is easier to work
with and that's why Silicon Valley is
called Silicon Valley if germanium had
been easier to work with it be called
germanium and and so what a noises view
was I want to make a company work for me
rather than work for the company and as
long as that's true I'm gonna stay with
a company if it stops being true I'll
found my own so the whole venture
capital ethos that started in Silicon
Valley and has spread throughout the
world wasn't some important part a
result of Bob Noyce in his efforts so
through these seven people I try to show
how the country changed I try to show
how they embraced technology how they
either invented it as noise did or
Exploited it the way Carnegie did before
Andrew Carnegie steel was sold by the
pound after him it was sold by the ton
and I also try to draw some some lessons
from these people they were very
different but they had certain traits in
common and apparently it's resonated
enough so that Business Week has put it
on its list of top ten business books
and in the year 2001 which makes me very
happy and it makes my publisher very
happy too so that said you know I'd be
happy to keep talking or be happy to
take questions about any of these any of
these people or about the book and how
it got started yes I know that Carnegie
had a unusual relationship with his
mother
yes Eastman had a very unusual
relationship with his yes I've met Noyce
a number of times because I've worked in
the semiconductor business since 1960
and by the way I'm surprised you didn't
mention Sherman Fairchild who was the
business man really who created noise he
brought noise to Silicon Valley I'm
pretty sure I don't know if you know
that and and in fact no your while
you're right about the technology noise
developed the planar process
he killed the invented the integrated
circuit noise developed the planar
process which makes it feasible to
manufacture these things yes but I
wondered if there is something about
these other people something about their
mothers I mean I remember when Dukakis
was running against bush back in 1968 it
was it radiates it was interesting
Dukakis had a 92 year old mother who he
worshiped Bush had a still-living 92
year old mother are these people driven
by their mothers as much as anything
else cannot before I talk about these
people and their mothers which by the
way is quite interesting it's
interesting that you picked up on that
and it's variants ting let me say world
it word about Sherman Fairchild he is in
the book I didn't mention him in the
introduction Sherman Fairchild father
was a man named George Fairchild George
Fairchild was the first CEO of computing
tabulating recording in 1911 when that
firm was founded George W Fairchild who
was a Republican congressman from New
York State was the CEO of CTR computing
tabulating and recording they got rid of
him and brought in Tom Watson's senior
but obviously the stock stayed in the
family so Sherman Fairchild is George
ferret was George Fairchild
son and Sherman Fairchild founded
Fairchild camera and instrument and
right and he used to fly around and take
pictures
and by the way there on the web look up
the Sherman Fairchild you can find that
there at Whittier College you can find
Sherman Fairchild pictures on the web
when Tom Watson's senior died in 1956
Sherman Fairchild was the largest holder
of stock in IBM the the man who brought
noise out to Silicon Valley was actually
not Sherman Fairchild it was William
Shockley the who started no he started
his own firm Shockley semiconductor
Shockley was the co-inventor of the
transistor at AT&T
but Shockley was a nut nobody could
stand working for him and so noise
gordon moore was still alive and moore's
law obviously you know this industry
what have you and a whole bunch of other
people six other people left Shockley to
go to Fairchild Semiconductor and they
are the people who were called the
traitorous eight that's what Shockley
called them and that was the beginning
of we're gonna leave the company if we
don't like the company let's talk about
the mothers of these characters for
because it's really quite interesting by
the way there is a passage in here about
the death of Henry Ford's mother which
is ratted I find rather touching I mean
if you read the the inscription on her
tombstone I mean clearly you know Ford
himself didn't like farms
it was the mother on the farm that he
loved and when she was gone he was out
Carnegie and Eastman both lived in a pre
Freudian age so you know to to be openly
enamored and attached as much as these
characters were to their mother to their
respective mothers didn't carry with it
you know the have you seen a shrink
lately kind of question that it would
today with Carnegie his relationship to
his mother was I mean it was it was like
this a Carnegie's father was a failure
in business and his mother wasn't
interested in failure
she had an iron backbone and she was she
was bound and determined that that her
son was going to be a success he himself
was very involved with her
and he he meets the woman that he
eventually marries Louise Whitfield in
1880 and Louise understands when she
sees Carnegie with his mother that
there's going to be no marriage while
his mother lives and his mother dies
Carnegie's mother dies in 1886 and
Carnegie marries in 1887 when he's 51
years old and you know he just waited
that long I mean he could as long as his
mother was living he wasn't going to be
married Louise Carnegie who knew how to
be the wife of a great man and loved
Carnegie truly as I believe he loved her
later recalled this isn't a memoir at
the Columbia oral history collection in
New York City that Margaret Carnegie was
one of the most unpleasant women she had
ever met in her life
they Andrew Carnegie and and Louise had
one child a girl and the child was named
Margaret after Carnegie's mother I'm
absolutely convinced that if the child
had been a boy they would have called it
Margaret anyway as far as Eastman was
concerned he was also he was also a man
whose father failed in business died
relatively young left the family not
with assets but with debts he was poor
and his mother took in boarders was a
fighter and was quite withholding you
know she seemed to be extremely hard to
please but he was deeply enamored of her
when she died at an advanced age I
believe in 1907 I'd have to take a look
at the book was after the turn of the
century he said I wept openly I cried
all day I couldn't have stopped crying
to save my life he never married one of
the very few I have a database which is
more academically oriented and is not in
this book of 250 executives who ran
major companies in 1917 only a handful
never married Eastman is one of that
handful he was married to his company
and when he finally stopped working for
the company because of age and because
his physical health began to deteriorate
he committed suicide
and left a note that said to my friends
my work is over why wait and but his
connection and is his his his connection
to his mother could hardly have been
stronger as a matter of fact the name
Kodak the reason that Eastman chose that
name was he he wanted a name that
started with K because her maiden name
was kill born and he wanted a name that
was going to have her maiden names
letter and he also needed a name that
didn't mean anything in any language so
that he could trade market so he came up
with Kodak himself but you know it's
it's interesting when you look at
nineteenth-century characters well you
see this a lot I mean people who are
deeply attached to their mother Franklin
Roosevelt for example is a
twentieth-century character born in the
19th century who could hardly have been
more attached to Sara Delano Roosevelt
you see this a lot and anything annoys
cuz noise had an unusual domestic life I
forgot what it was but I well noise
noise was divorced in 1974 he married a
woman named Elizabeth Bottomly when he
was here in Boston as a graduate student
at MIT noise was a polymath one of the
things he did was act and he was acting
in a play and she was working behind
literally behind the scenes as a
costumer he met her she saw him as a
graduate student and and and before he
was a great man and they had five
children they went first to Philadelphia
where he worked for Philco and then out
to Silicon Valley and she did really she
did not like being mrs. Bob Noyce she
wanted to be Elisabeth Bottomly noise I
mean she thought to have an identity for
herself which was very hard around moist
because noise was a man of enormous
charisma and so eventually they were
divorced he was remarried his widow is
still alive I met her in the course went
forth on this book
Elizabeth Bottomly moved back to Maine
they had a house in Maine on 50 acres in
Bremen Maine and she set up a foundation
the Libre Foundation which donates money
specifically to Maine based enterprises
but she
she died in the 1990s and she I've been
told I've played a very important role
in the rebuilding of downtown Portland
so and noise his daughter lives in the
Boston metropolitan area she lives in in
Weston
she left Silicon Valley in the words of
the immortal words of Joni Mitchell they
paved paradise and put in a parking lot
that's what happened to Silicon Valley
yes
well please well two things if you look
back that entrepreneurs are sometimes
accused of exploiting poor people with
Carnegie and the homestead of strike and
on the other hand he did a lot of good
so far as world peace and their and so I
wonder if you could comment on those
aspects of him and then Sam Walton yeah
he helped a lot of people buy goods
cheaply but my complaint about Sam
Walton is he's put a lot of little
businesses out of business Oh thousands
around the country so if could you
address those aspects of those two men
in terms of the common everyday person
and a small business owner their
relationships with them and their affect
on them let me start with Walton okay
if Sam Walton were Sam Walton died in
1992 right if he were here right now and
he heard you say mr. Walton you put a
lot of small business people out of
business his response would be I didn't
put them out of business their customers
put them out of business that's what
he'd say he'd say you know we live in a
free country I sell the best for less
you can get Crest toothpaste more
cheaply or a GE lightbulb more cheaply
in my store than you can at the store on
Main Street so it's the people who do
that now that to a certain extent is an
in genuine genuine argument because a
lot of times these Walmart's would move
to the outskirts of town where parking
was plentiful and rents were low and
sometimes they would literally you know
put all those small companies out of
business then find their own stores were
not sufficiently profitable so they
leave and there'd be no stores left at
all not even a Walmart but most of that
kind of activity frankly took place
after Walton had left the active
management
company he began to give the to pass the
baton in 1988-89 and passed away in 1992
and it's really after them that Walmart
has been charged with these kinds of
problems nevertheless you know in this
country you know if you can sell for
less you get a hearing you know and
that's that's how Walton felt as far as
Carnegie is concerned I think the
picture is actually darker than then
Walton Carnegie in addition to being a
very seductive character in addition to
being a very appealing character was a
hypocrite if you read what he wrote
about labor unions it was the thing they
were their greatest thing since night
baseball and then when his plant the
Homestead plan and if you're from
Pittsburgh yeah you know when that was
Union I you know it was not at my plant
I didn't mean there I mean you know I'm
for unions it's somebody else's plans
and so he felt that the amalgamated
Association of iron and steel workers
which unionized had that plant unionized
that that Union had to be broken why
because as one of his partners put it
the amalgamated put a tax on efficiency
so the amalgamated had to go carnegie
understood that steel was going to
change the material basis of
civilization
so his idea to fulfill his destiny he
wanted to be the king of steel in order
to be the king of steel you had to be
the low-cost producer in order to be the
low-cost producer you had to control
what was going on on the factory floor
of those production facilities if they
were unionized you couldn't do that so
the Union had to go no matter what he
had written in the forum magazine in
1886 he had local motors named after the
workers celebrated this guy and when
that when a time came to break the Union
you couldn't find Andrew Carnegie with a
search party he had decamped to a remote
fastness in Britain and he let a totally
unreconstructed capitalist named Henry
Clay Frick take care of this almost at
the cost of fixed life there was an
assassination attempt on him he was shot
twice and stabbed and with two bullets
in him and stab wounds
before he would allow himself to be
taken to the hospital he first wrote a
letter to his mother in what in which he
said mom I'm fine
don't worry and then he wrote a news
release to the people on strike that
said I have been shot I don't know
whether I am going to die or not it
doesn't matter
the Carnegie corporations policies are
not going to change and we will win then
he said okay good take me to a doctor
that's 19th century capitalism for you
yeah but look these people had the
defects of their virtues there's no
question about it the virtue was the
searing insight the virtue was the
ambition the defect in that in the case
of Carnegie was you know he says one
thing and does another there's a word
for it Nords hip hypocrisy the problem
with Walton is not so much that he was a
hypocrite matter of fact he was quite
empathetic with both his customers and
the people his employees the problem
with Walton is the problem with
capitalism which is that somebody can be
a very nice decent person working in a
very nice decent store and be put out of
business by somebody who has got a
better business model down the road and
and and there's a there's an unforgiving
nature to that that it's just very hard
to deny back in Carnegie's day - in
terms of collusion in terms of how you
treated employees you could you could
get away with a lot more right yes and
by the way I know you say Carnegie has a
true Pittsburgher and the rest of us say
Carnegie but the roles were different
that's one of Carnegie's ironmasters
said I've always had one rule when a
workman sticks up his head hit it that's
not the sort of thing you know a bit
business executives may feel that way
these days but they're not usually
quoted as saying that sort of thing
and also during the homestead strike as
you may know when when Frick was having
trouble he just got in touch with the
governor of Pennsylvania and said how
about some troops they called an estate
militia and that's really what broke the
strike it's not so easy to do that these
days General Motors tried that in 1936
37 1 there was a 44 day strike a
sit-down strike in Flint Michigan and
governor Frank Murphy at Michigan
refused to call in the strikes
that's why General Motors lost that
strike and that's why there's United
Automobile Workers today in this country
times change so yes will you carry on
what you started with Carnegie about the
searing insights of people you killed a
little bit about why he how he worked
the way he did what were this searing
insights of the others each one of them
each one a little Avraham each one of
them saw something that people around
them didn't see and more than that and
this is very important first they saw it
then they were able to express it in a
in a very clear simple way so that they
could communicate it and then they were
able to act on those three things it's
not just having an idea ideas are a dime
a dozen being able to implement and and
and being able to express and
communicate all of them were able to do
all those three things so if you take as
an example
Kodak you know you press the button we
do the rest I mean what could be simpler
he democratized photography photography
before George Eastman was only for the
very rich yes please did you ever kind
of piggyback on that a little bit and I
I I thought of one other person I was
wondering why he didn't include him in
the book and that was mr. Hershey who
who democratized chocolate and well you
there there are I'd say two to three
dozen other people who could have been
chosen who could have been chosen but
they're not five dozen other people who
could have been chosen huh Hershey is
one example I'm sure he wanted to know
and and and and maybe that was one of
the things that drove him I mean I don't
know but there are you know these people
were out of a set of true Titans people
who are above and beyond who had these
searing insights that I mentioned Henry
Ford understood that if you keep the
price of a car or low the size of the
market is gonna grow so much that
what you lose on margin you can make up
on volume nobody else understood that as
well as he did and that's why he
captured the market Tom Watson's as I
said understood that business is about
information so when he had to choose
between computing tabulating and
recording he chose tabulating because
that recorded information Charles Revson
understood among other things that you
can make you can find hope in a jar yeah
you know they say that women buy
cosmetics because they buy hope in the
factory we filled with chemicals and the
beauty probably sell hope and also
Revson understood albeit he was dragged
grudgingly he understood the power of
television these P didn't invent
television but he understood how to
exploit a new technology Walton what was
the Syrian site small towns can support
big stores noise what was the Syrian
side you can make companies work for you
rather than working for the company and
if you do that you can release you can
release a great deal of energy and
that's you know Intel which he
co-founded it along with Gordon Moore in
1968 you know over the past thirty four
years or whatever three has been one of
the most profitable companies in the
world and you know the reasons include
his charisma as well as his technical
abilities this is an altogether
remarkable man really had democratic--
with a small d-- ideas that could
benefit the masses and and uplift the
whole living standard of the country yes
yes that's true and and and although
they themselves in the process of
uplifting the country in the process of
benefiting the masses putting America on
wheels for example making steel cheap
you name it
enrich themselves enormous lee and as
they did that they themselves with the
exception of Walton lost the common
touch and and we're deranged by the
power and that they themselves
accumulated yes
Carnegie I believe was a Methodist right
a very pretty religious Methodist and
well I learned somewhere and of course I
took once in the welfare state that the
motto earned on you can conserve all you
can
that sounds very greedy then give all
you can and that's sort of what he did I
don't know about Eastman but Rockefeller
who you don't talk about well very
religious yes sir Baptist I don't know
about walk I just wondered if religion
that kind of thing also drives some of
these people it should but in least in
the ones that I've studied it doesn't
there is an enormous literature on the
Protestant ethic and the spirit of
capitalism which is this very title of a
book by Marx Weber Max Weber and there
is the belief that out of the out of
Protestantism was released a whole a
whole set of permissions to become
capitalistic but more than that as Weber
himself says in the prosthetic and
spirit of capitalism behavior that in
the Middle Ages and in other cultures
would be considered the lowest form of
avarice all of a sudden in the new
capitalist culture is considered your
duty it's your duty to grow rich and
this this was this was news my
impression of Carnegie from what I read
is that he was an atheist that he liked
going ice-skating on Sundays and was it
was it was not a religious man he was
however and this point you made and it
deserves emphasis somebody who believed
that to use his own words he who dies
rich dies disgraced and he disgraced
that that was his word he who dies rich
dies disgraced I'm not too worried about
this myself but you know for a man like
that who was the richest man in the
world 1901 it's a potential problem and
he gave away a great fortune and there
are a lot of libraries named Carnegie
and there's the Carnegie Endowment for
international peace there's the peace
palace in The Hague Carnegie Hall
there's the teachers insurance an
annuity Association and the
College retirement equities fund he
founded dia a Carnegie Carnegie Mellon I
mean he gave away literally
unfortunately occurred they have tarred
when he was approaching death or no it
was the log of twenty to thirty years
before he died no you're quite right he
was giving away money earlier than that
ya know he felt early on that write a
conscious a social conscious yes and
forg I mean I you said he had a dark
side to him yes I was I read a long
biography about him for about thirty
years ago but I remember that and by the
way lowering prices I think that was an
accident he he was embarrassed that the
profits he would be making in a certain
year so he lowered the price of his car
the next year and that would increase
the size of the market so much that he
made even more profit isn't that I think
that's it was my my about look first of
all what you're saying is true but my
impression about 40s he wasn't that
embarrassed by all that profit well okay
but but he was involved in social action
like after World War one sort of naive
but then they have a shift or something
that oh yes yes did seem to be a have an
altruistic side there was no money
involved in that as far as I can see no
he did you're quite right
a charter a ship the oscar ii which he
sailed to norway in the hopes of the the
utterly naive and foolish hope he saw
woodrow wilson first when you have a
billion dollars you can see the
president of course that was back in
nineteen fifteen when a billion dollars
was considered a lot of money you you
know and he thought that he literally
could bring peace to the world now this
this was a megalomaniacal and ridiculous
idea which had no no grounding in what
was really going on in europe and so
when he finally got and ought to norway
didn't know what to say and really and
so he was a reclusive for a while and
then finally he said he was willing to
give he developed a tractor by this time
that ford ford zyada and russian and
well-known tractor globally sold he said
he was willing to give his tractors away
without a patent and people would do
much better using tractors than using
tanks and one of the Norwegians who
heard him say
this say this said it must be a very
great man who can say such stupid things
and in fact there is a word in Norwegian
store moms gals cop which means great
man's madness and that's what they felt
Henry Ford suffered from that's not to
say that he was totally without
philanthropic and so you know impulse we
what locally here benefit from this
because the way sighted in Sudbury which
he renovated but in his later years
these were the years of his
anti-semitism these were the years where
we're talking about the only American
who's favorably mentioned in mind Kampf
not something you want on your resume
okay III think Hitler was interested in
motorizing Germany and he saw that I
don't know if he was talking about his
political views was he wasn't he talking
about his industrial balls both in fact
in the Soviet Union there's a big Ford
plant - I think under yes he probably
knew new Lenin and Stalin and people
like that I'm not sure he knew them but
they probably admired him - they did and
that doesn't make him a good guy either
Lenin Stalin and Hitler the mother
Teresa side I don't know where you work
but I know Hitler specifically and in
fact let's let's be even more specific
let's take that the leader of the Hitler
Youth Baldur von Schirach
a thoroughly grotesque character who at
his at the trial in Nuremberg said that
one of the reasons he became an
anti-semite was Henry Ford's advocacy of
it and he had read Ford's or the
Dearborn independent where he was saying
that you know Jews are themes and
publishing the this forgery called the
protocols of the Elders of Zion and all
the rest of it and moreover Hitler too
pointed to this now I'm not saying the
Hitler would not have been an
anti-semite had it not been for Henry
Ford you know but I'm saying that Ford
didn't do the world any good by giving
these people are further excused to say
look at the greatest industrialist in
America Henry Ford alone stands out
against their power
that's almost a direct quote from mine
Kampf you don't want this and it didn't
have to happen it was just his there was
an evil side of that man an unappealing
side won't believe me you're happy
you're not having dinner with him
tonight trust me on that
yes basic to us now but how were they
encountered when they first came out
with them with incredulity they do seem
basic to us now which by the way is one
reason I like being an historian I
unlike all my colleagues at the Harvard
Business School I I can't predict the
future but I can predict the past so
yeah I mean no coca-cola shouldn't have
changed the formula in 1985 you see I'm
always right so with the benefit of
hindsight the idea that steel rails
rather than iron rails in a three
million square mile country are going to
be absolutely critical for the railroad
which is going to be absolutely critical
for the advancement of civilization that
does seem obvious but to raise the
capital to take the chance to really
believe that you can do it to scrap and
built I'll always be the low-cost
supplier that takes I mean a fundamental
belief and insight against a lot and
another good example is Ford in Henry
Ford the good you know the not the
Wicked Witch of the East here but how
many for the good if you look at him in
the early years
I'm telling if you there's a book called
conspicuous production it's a wonderful
book no one reads but by man named
Donald Finley Davis published by Temple
University Press which which documents
how how the impulse of everybody making
automobiles was to go up market to make
them fancier and more expensive why is
that that's right it's because they
viewed it as like a land yacht they
viewed it as a plaything for the rich
Henry Ford had a democratizing impulse
he wanted to make it available to
everybody and he was convinced as he put
it once at a trial that if you do that
the money will just fall on you but this
was not an obvious idea at all that some
day in 1900 if you had taken a poll of
Americans and don't take my word for
this because I've done a lot of reading
on this too because this is an important
point in the book
if you had taken a poll of among
Americans and said will there ever be a
mass market an automobile the answer
would have been no in 1900 there were
only 40 192 automobiles sold in the
United States by the 1920s there were
millions and that's because Ford kept
pushing the price down and making it all
up in volume and on spare parts he was
making him fight by 1925 almost nothing
on the car itself but there were so many
of the installed base there was so many
out there they need two spare parts so
the idea that that you should start a
nail polish I see your lovely nail
polish that you should that that you
should start a nail polish company on
March 1st 1932 with $300 of paid in
capital no brand name that this was a
good idea this is not obvious that's not
obvious the idea that that after
building a business as Revson did on the
basis of these advertisements and you
haven't lived really until you see these
ads from vogue and other high-fashion
women's magazines from the early 1950s
about these these utterly strange
creatures who these models do I don't
know where they find these people but
they all look like hard-hearted Hannah
the vamp of Savannah she pour water on a
drowning man basically the idea that you
could move from that androgynous
sexually confused presentation of a
product to the $64,000 question which in
1955 all television was black and white
and what Revlon was selling was color
and now they're having to put their ads
on in black and white I mean this is
quite a transition and a lot of other
companies didn't do it yes
Giants Enterprise as you call them how
they affected the political landscape of
the specific times in which they lived
operated did things I mean in terms of
presidential politics or things like
that I mean how exactly what was the
effect mom the one who had the greatest
impact on American presidential politics
at the presidential level was
unquestionably Thomas Watson senior who
became the I believe he was the
president of the Board of Trustees
whether or not he was the president he
was the most important member of the
Board of Trustees of Columbia University
and it was he who made it possible for
Dwight D Eisenhower to become president
of Columbia University between this
happened between 1945 when I when world
war ii ended eisenhower had been you
know the the the leading soldier in our
armed forces not the commander in chief
the president United States is the
commander-in-chief but he had been the
highest-ranking soldier in the US Armed
Forces between that time and the time
that he ran for the presidency in 1952
Tom Watson senior enabled him to have a
you know the perfect platforms become
the president of a major University
Columbia others of them knew a lot of
presidents Carnegie knew eaters you know
seven or eight presidents literally but
as far as their impact on President
Henry Ford ran for the Senate once
almost one destroyed the man who beat
him and who wound up resigning from the
Senate because he just couldn't stand it
but a by and large these people were not
really involved with presidential
politics that much you'd think they
would have been more updated H Ross
Perot for example is not the kind of
character that you that you see
historically in the United States
different from other countries that way
these are individuals of great wealth
and in local and state politics where
their plants are located people of
enormous power but who cares about the
president Washington is a long way away
and you know yes
to mention that occurs to me is dynasty
I Eastman had no children Oh Carnegie
has one daughter he probably is obscure
remson I think had a son who got killed
in an auto way that was his nephew Peter
Rustin okay so I don't know if he has a
family but yes that was I'm wondering if
there is almost a negative element to
these giants when it comes to their
their dynasties I mean Ford Ford's
dynasty is strange also Oh
good day oh no there's a great grandson
I guess who's now running it but he's up
to his ears in troubles you bet there's
a great grandson who's now the chief
executive officer of it I'm not sure
whether he's running it curse yeah well
it's a 180 billion dollar corporation
and it's now being one run by William
clay Ford Jr who is the great grandson
not only of Henry Ford but of Harvey
Firestone there's slight problems there
and and that is an it's a Ford alone
among the people in this book found at a
dynasty john d rockefeller who is not
covered in this book and the reason I
chose Carnegie instead of rockefeller is
because there's been so much written on
Rockefeller lately that I thought I had
more original to say about Carnegie made
a point of not founding a dynasty I mean
he left enough money so his daughter
could put food on the table don't you
don't get me wrong but he didn't leave
billions Reston didn't found a dime
stealing there was plenty of money there
neither did noise neither to the others
and by and large in American business
it's pretty rare you don't maybe it's
smart because in order to create the the
the enterprise they have had to create
so much animosity that their children
would become targets
which in fact does happen so I'd you see
what I'm saying oh I think it does
happen people blame all the descendants
of Rockefeller for what the original
Rockefeller did you're quite right so
maybe it's smart to not create a
prominent dynasty because they will end
up like this William clay Ford who's now
stuck running this
you know instead of enjoying the 1,000
acres in Telluride I you know I maybe it
is to be the child of a great figure in
business is not that you know on the one
hand the money is great and it's hard to
say you know I'd rather not have it on
the other hand when you look at what
happened if you look at what happened to
the children of Edsel Ford it was Henry
Ford's son you look at these kids I
would I wouldn't swap my life for theirs
you know their fates were really not
that bad happy people in our country are
judged by what they do more than by what
they inherit and when you inherit a
great deal the temptation to become a
dilettante the temptation to be courted
simply so people can get you to donate
money to their cause not because of
something that you bring to the party
intellectually or that you've developed
from within yourself is very great and
and and that's not terribly appealing
you got there living here that's right
yeah yeah you got there because of your
your parents influence not because of
your own ability and in this this is not
you know this country purports to be
doesn't always live up to this but
purports to be a meritocracy you you get
it because of your merit and and you
know by and large let's take two cases
let's take somebody worth 20 million
dollars in somebody worth ten million
dollars okay five years ago the person
worth 10 million dollars wasn't worth a
penny we tend to admire that starts from
nothing earns 10 million dollars the guy
worth 20 million dollars ten years ago
was worth 40 million so he managed to
have the he's got twice as much as the
guy worth 10 but we tend to look up to
the guy worth 10 a lot more than we do
to the guy worth 20 it's just our
culture you know it's the ambience in
which we live being the child of great
wealth is not you know it's very hard to
say I'm gonna give all the money away
but it's you know there's a biblical
verse you know if you really want to go
to heaven give all your money away and
follow me and the rich guy walks away
and says work I'm not sure that's a
great idea
Warren Buffett promises to do that
doesn't be a Warren Buffett my
understanding is it's going to give away
almost all his money to Planned
Parenthood and to
other charitable organizations yeah he's
not he's making a point out of not
founding a dynasty money can ruin people
yes each of seven people that that you
researched you write about you try them
as having searing insight and was there
certain context cultural context then
able this for them like you know absence
sitting in the theater maybe thinking
about adding a touch of glamour
someone's life maybe being a lonely
person I don't know it was their
commonality with these seven figures
yeah you bet commonalities that they
roll in the US of A they're all
Protestants to know Charles Rustin was
Jewish but they're all American and and
if you take a look at the way the book
begins it says you know this is a book
about what Americans do best found and
nurture new businesses this is a country
in which it's okay to fail and try again
they're there until recently there are
countries wealthy countries where if you
go bank if you lose the right to vote
that's never been part of our culture
you've had permission to fail and to try
again and and that's been encouraged
Henry Ford failed twice with the Henry
Ford company in the Detroit automobile
company not in that order of Detroit or
a veal company came first before
founding the Ford Motor Company uh well
he was in various contraptions he tried
anything mechanical and he was a great
mechanic but that's what they had in
common and that that's America's culture
and that goes back to Benjamin Franklin
they know this idea that you can try and
that you can do things yourself and rise
by your own efforts that's the cultural
context in which all these people lived
and which mattered a lot did Ford
democratize the car for financial
reasons or for altruistic reasons or
both but the real answer to that
question is he did it because he had to
do it and it and the truth is he didn't
he was the most unsightly minded man in
the world if you had asked him why he
did something he wouldn't have been able
to give you a straight answer
he wouldn't know
he just it was inside him to do it what
made you stop at these seven I mean why
not ten and who who and if you do a
second book like eight uh you know eight
to fifteen who's it gonna be who are the
next seven well first of all let me say
that one of the qualifications to be in
this book is that you have to have
already gone to your great reward so
there is no one in the book who is still
living no no no no because I want to
know what the answer is
and you know you know what 60 billion
book sixty billion this is confidential
but that's more money than I have
however he was once worth a hundred
billion and because of an utterly
unnecessary point of view that he took
with regard to the antitrust authorities
of the federal government in one day
when Judge Thomas Penfield Jackson
issued his findings of fact in nineteen
ninety nine the stock price that the
market capitalization of Microsoft
dropped by a quarter of a trillion
dollars that's a lot of money and it
didn't have to happen I don't you know I
know without knowing I'm willing to bet
that he didn't sell short because if he
sold short he'd be behind bars yes
that's right uh but once again without
knowing my guess is that the way Bill
Gates sells stock is that he's seen the
corporate lawyer and they sell on some
sort of regular basis since he knows
what's going on in the company at all
times it must just happen automatically
there must be some you know plan because
otherwise you'd never be able to sell
any of it he'd never be liquid but but
so yeah fifty billion is a lot and look
Microsoft is I mean how many of us have
Linux you know what's what's what's
sheriff market does Linux have point
zero zero zero one not very high you
know we all have we all have Windows on
my computer in order to in order to what
I try to turn my computer off when I
want to turn my computer off which I do
for two reasons something goes wrong you
know the first thing you do is you call
the helplessness desk and then that
doesn't work out
so then you you turn it off in the hope
that it'll fix itself
that's one reason and the other reason
is to sort of show it you know and now
when you turn your computer off where do
you learn move the cursor where do you
move it yes and what is what does it say
on the lower left-hand corner start so
you want to stop and you move to start I
see that is that it's the whole thing's
counterintuitive it's ridiculous I mean
it's not inconceivable to me that
somebody will come up with a way of
making a computers makes sense except
that your car would break down
occasionally and you would merely pull
it over to the side and restart your car
yeah well the guy former CEO of General
Motors he's very funny about that you
know if it was gates criticized
automobiles and he said if we made
automobiles the way you make computers
they crash all the time and so I I'm not
saying it's almost inconceivable to me
that a book on giants of enterprise
written in 50 years wouldn't include
Bill Gates it would also include Oprah
Winfrey it would also a next question I
was leading into that if go ahead
absolutely who's gonna be the next seven
that's my question well first of all the
next book is not gonna be on those seven
the next book is gonna be specifically
on the Watson family that contracts
already been signed uh but I certainly
think that someone like Oprah Winfrey
who is this remarkable african-american
woman who once again was a bootstrap
story nobody gave her anything she came
from nowhere and created this new
reality I gotta tell you this wonderful
book which I hope that you all buy
thousands of copies of if this should
get on Oprah Winfrey's book club my life
will be changed for me what you're
saying right now by Dell all I can do is
hope I'm not sure this you know but you
know there's so you got Gates Winfrey
who else um today you know you'd really
have to deal if you had asked me six
months ago I'm gonna say the CEO of
Enron I don't think so No
it had eighty billion dollar market
capitalization now you could buy it for
eight cents you know and a lot of
lawyers fees among people who are living
Larry Ellison certainly might be one of
Oracle perhaps Tom Murphy Warren Buffett
I think would have to be on the list
no problem well now if we're talking
about business executives specifically
really is a remarkable person but anyway
ya know if I'm Sarah if you want to talk
about politicians then then there's a
different set category of politician
he's a almost an entrepreneur in this
way he turned around the whole world you
know but anyway well no no no look
Reagan mattered a lot and it's
astonishing you know how far you can go
was with with with such little you know
with with such little going on between
your ears Reagan himself once said and
one of the one of the remarkably
accurate remarks he said that I don't
see said people keep accusing me of
being an actor he said I don't say I
could have the job and not be an actor
and and one of one of the things that
Reagan understood was that it's more
important if you're gonna be President
temperament is more important than
intellect Jimmy Carter I'm without
knowing my guest has did better on his
college boards than Ronald Reagan did on
his college sports but Reagan was a more
successful president because he
understood that being the president is
about being leader and is about spirit
and it's about being in this morning in
America you remember that phrase where
as Cardinal to me anyway a very adamant
one is parmie you talking about movie
talked about the land make me feel great
you know I mean you know and and he wore
the president's he'd like a cross he
acted like he was doing me a favor by
being president but know if you take a
look at business executives it seems to
me Jack Welch but I mean when he took
that company over GE I mean in it was in
either 19 it was in 1980 or 1981 Jim do
you remember offhand 81 when he became
the CEO G and had a market
capitalization of 13 billion dollars and
now it has a market capitalization my
guess is of between four and five
hundred billion without having checked
I'd say something like that
I think James Burke CEO of Johnson &
Johnson when tylenol was tampered with
he was a CEO from 1976 to 1989 probably
would be on this list because he's a
remarkable example of what business at
its best really can be there were a
couple of others that you don't see Jeff
Bezos if you had asked me that question
two years ago I would have said for sure
yes now I would say I'm not so sure
after Amazon is bought by Walmart
remember you heard it here first I mean
that's gonna be an extremely powerful
business model I would also add Roberto
goys waiter who is the chief executive
officer of coca-cola once again I can't
remember what it was 1980 or 81 that he
took the company over but when he took
it over and had a tiny martyr it had a
market capitalisation of 4.3 billion
dollars when he died in 1987 1997 excuse
me it had a market capitalization of 180
billion so and we're talking about
sugared flavored water here not
integrated circuits I mean this is
something anybody can make soda turns to
turn that into a hundred and eighty
billion dollars that's business genius
so his successors haven't been able to
his success was a flop flopped around
like a fish Oprah Winfrey Oprah Winfrey
without question and although I say it
with some reluctance I think Martha
Stewart oh are you a fan I mean too much
time in the dentist's office remarked
Martha Stewart is turning nothing into
everything well that's right she turned
nothing into something and nothing with
a capital and I don't mean I don't
understand that phenomenon so but but I
would also say there's a number of women
one who I'm embarrassed to say his name
slips my mind right now but she founded
Nickelodeon but so you know I can't
remember her name but she was an
entrepreneur and is an entrepreneur is
very important and in the in the media
world today
that's a very interesting choice Mary
Kay Ash of Mary Kay Cosmetics Estee
Lauder who has not yet gone to a great
reward I think she's in her 90s but that
would be another example and you know
had she died in 1975 and her company I
would have used her instead of Revlon so
I but but you know no I think that there
are a whole set of women that you can
look at now that were not really
available historically in the United
States at the level of the kind of Titan
hood or Titan ship or Titanic I guess
level that the people that these yes sir
be happy to take one or two more are
there one or two more well yeah you
mentioned you left Rockefeller out
because so much your environment yes who
are the other Titans that you left out
and why well the the the the set of
people that you were close to is that
are you the set of people who are known
as robber barons were born in the 1830s
Carnegie was born in 1835 JP Morgan is
not in the book he was born in 1837
Rockefeller is not in the book
he was born in 1839 so any one of those
three were sufficiently titanic there
are a number of people whose names are
not household words now but well when
they were at their peak like Henry
Kaiser for example the great ship
builder the Maverick Jay Gould would be
another very good example the great
railroad entrepreneur these are all
people who are of the class who were
true movers and shakers who could have
been and could be in another book like
this yeah you could come up with a set
but the list wouldn't be that long it'd
be a couple of dozen but not ten dozen
Joe Kennedy Joe Kennedy is an
interesting case and by the way the
presidential politics question my
understanding is 1960 Joe Kennedy was
the 11th richest man in United States
and that's why John Kennedy became
president I mean because Illinois went
democratic and Mayor Daley was Richard
daily was the mayor of Chicago at the
time and when the Kennedys were worried
about which way Chicago was going to go
and how many votes it was going to
deliver to the Democrats they phoned him
from my honest part I understand
and they said how's it going to go and
Daly responded by the grace of God and
with the help of some very good friends
John F Kennedy is going to take Illinois
and he did I mean you know the old
saying in Chicago was vote early vote
often
he took a cog oh because of the
graveyard well Kennedy's a good example
though of business involvement in
presidential politics and there I don't
think is another example in all of
American history of a very wealthy
businessman literally putting us not
literally but doing a great deal to put
his son in the White House yes very
close yeah there's been so much written
about him and I I wanted to put people
in my book who I thought I could say
something new about not that many people
know that much about Charles Revson
there's a lot known about Andrew
Carnegie but I think I have a new angle
on Carnegie yeah that's my view and when
I when I saw that I did I thought I'd
like to start with him rather than this
Rockefeller or I think that I say things
about four that I've never read any
place else that I think were original
so what I wanted to do was just not
choose just Titans but choose Titans
that I thought I could say something
original about yes because women could
not be found
giant enterprises that they did it
through their sons
aye sir that's as good a that's as good
a hypothesis is any but you know he had
no idea whether they were
entrepreneurial ambitious Marvin Barney
just Margaret Carnegie was as ambitious
as any human being who ever lived in the
whole world and and she lived her
ambition through her son and that is
that's really a very good example of
precisely one last question yes ma'am
it's mother's keep coming up there's a
fascinating book that would be if maybe
a great companion to yours called first
mothers by I think her name is Bonnie
Danja
and it's a profile of the mothers of the
last 11 presidents and it's very much of
what you were saying about the mother
had a very special relationship with
this particular child who became
president and that the mothers were very
very ambitious well perhaps if we are
concluding now let me say that I am
second to none in might have you
conceived motherhood